we've seen the backlog of goods stuck at
the port of los angeles not only in the
water but also on land items are just
slowly getting on the road and then
eventually to store shelves right
companies having trouble even hiring
enough workers to fill those trucks
hector mejia joining us live near
hacienda and arville explaining what
that means for us right here in the
valley hector good morning
good morning it could lead to higher
prices for us in the end we are at a
local trucking company this morning this
is their yard we're at desert eagle
transportation where they tell us they
are having a hard time finding workers
they have about 50 of these trucks but
five of these trucks cannot move they're
stuck here because again they're having
a hard time finding enough people to
drive these trucks and we've learned
companies are paying more for shipping
than ever before nationally suppliers
say they are not able to get items to
stores fast enough in part because
there's a shortage of warehouse workers
along with truck drivers with more than
half a million job openings and there's
also a lot of competition between
companies to hire enough staffing
it's all supply and demand
christmas season is coming so
we're gonna
expect some delays for sure
there is not enough trucks and it's a
challenge with the drivers and
everything
desert eagle transportation adds this is
a tough job they cover 48 states
although they mostly serve the west
coast since the pandemic they mostly
transport food and consumer products and
they are hiring here if you're thinking
about a career change we checked in with
the local dmv office to find out what
the process is like to get your
commercial driver's license we'll cover
that as well as what companies are doing
to incentivize workers still ahead in
the next half hour reporting live hector
mejia live local now